안녕하세요 시도입니다 제 경험의
의거해 보면 주변을 둘러봤을 때 옷에
관심 갖는 분들은 많지만 그에 비해서
전체적인 스타일을 만드는 것에 관심을
갖는 분들은 상대적으로 적은 것
같습니다 그래서 오늘은 얼굴에 가장
가까운 액세서리이자 미세한 차이로
본인이 보여주고자 하는 인상을 바꿀
수 있는 안경에 대해서 얘기해 보고자
합니다 지난 영상들을 보신 분들은
아시겠지만 저는 안경을 꽤나
좋아합니다 다만 서두에 두 가지
말씀드리면 저는 도수 없는 블루라이트
안경을 써요 노트북 업무을 볼 때나
휴대폰을 할 때 안경이 없으면 저는
눈이 금방
건조해지고 물론 그렇긴 하지만 패션
안경이기도 합니다 두 번째로 저는
안경에 대해서 온만큼 알지 못합니다
그래서 제가 얕게나마 찾아보고 마음에
들게 된 브랜드의 제품들 혹은 유명한
모델이 주입니다 아무튼 제가 가진 몇
개 안경과이 안경을 어떤 느낌으로
제가 쓰고자 하는지를 소개해 드리고자
합니다 처음 소개해 드릴 제품은
올리버 피프 스의 그레고리 팩입니다
이건 제가 처음으로 구매한 외제
안경이에요 그 전까진 언커먼 아이웨어
애시크로프트 같은 국내 브랜드
안경들을 조금씩 착용하면서 어떤
안경이 제게 어울리는지를
알아갔습니다이 그래고리 팩을 구매한
이유는 주변에서 추천하기도 했지만
당시에 합리적인 가격에 떠서
그렇습니다
오케이몰에서 한 10만 원 후반 때
구매했었어요
만족도가 굉장히 높아서 블랙과
브라운을 모두 연이어 샀었습니다 이게
한국인에게 꽤 잘 어울리는 안경인지
제 회사 동기들도 써보고는 두세명
정도 똑같은 걸 구매했던 기억이
있습니다 제가 구매하고 오랫동안 잘
쓰고 있다가 몇 년 전쯤에야이 올리버
피스가 초기에 비해서 많이
아쉬워졌다이기를 했어요 올리버피플스
1987년 설립된 미국의 독립적인
안경 브랜드였지만
2006년쯤 대형 안경 기업인
룩소티카 인수되면서 그 모양새가 조금
바뀌었습니다 본래는 럭셔리한 느낌이
지배적인 브랜드였지만 대기업인
룩소티카 전 세계적인 판매를 진행하고
퀄리티 대비 가격이 오르면서 그
이미지가
퇴색됐다 보니 저같이 안경을 잘
모르던 사람도이 올리버피플스를 만나게
된 거고요 니치 안경의 이미지는
예전에 비해 약해졌을지 몰라도
2016년에 바이레도 그리고
2019년에는 더로우 협업을 하기도
했었습니다 올리버 피프스 a 여러
가지 인기 많은 모델 중 하나가
바로이 그레고리 팩입니다
모델의 이름은 영화 앵무새 죽이기에
나온 배우 그레고리 팩의 안경을 본다
만들어 이와 같이 지었다고 합니다
그레고리 팩은 꽤 오랫동안 제
데일리한 안경이 되어 준 제품인데요
안경 다리인 템플은 얇고 길게 빠져서
한국인에게 잘 어울리는 무난한 보스턴
형태의 뿔태 안경입니다 브라운 컬러의
그레고리 팩을 쓸 때는 갈색과
매칭하기도 하지만 또 브라운과 잘
어울리는 브레이너 초록색이 도는
상이를 같이 입어 주기도 합니다 안에
입은 반팔 셔츠는 한 6 7년 전쯤
홍대 라따몬따 구매한 빈티지 제품이고
겉에 입어 준 가디건은 르메르의 캐리
오버로 나오는 이사 SS 트위스티드
가디건입니다 물론 브라운이 대중적인
색상이 만 이런 조합이 아니더라도
다른 색감의 옷들과도 잘 어울려요
동그란 트라 지적인 느낌을
연출하기에도 좋습니다 블랙 컬러를 쓸
때는 검정을 같이 붙여서 좀 깔끔하게
연출하고자 합니다 제이부 말하기 좀
그렇지만 브라운에 비해서 이게 좀 더
도시적인 느낌이 드는 것 같아요
상위로 입은 라운드넥 가디건은
꼼데가르 송의 제품인데 아오야마
매장에서 한 2 3년 전쯤
구매했습니다 아무 로고도 없고 굉
정직한 라운드넥 가디건 인지라 제
수요의
안성맞춤이었습니다 당시 듣기로
아오야마 한정판이라고 하는데 아직
판매하는지는 잘 모르겠습니다 안경알이
동글동글해서 그런지이 그레고리 팩을
쓰면 뭔가 똑부러져 보인다는 얘기를
몇 번 들었는데 칭찬의 의미하는지는
잘 모르겠어요 두 번째 소개해드린
안경은 젠틀 몬스터와 매종 마르
젤라의 두 번째 협업 시리즈 중
mm12 모델의 블랙 제품입니다
이것도 구매한 이유를 솔직하게
말씀드리면 제가 마르지엘라는 브랜드를
좋아하기도 하지만 유행과 명성의
편승해 구매했습니다 쉽게 말해서 다들
사고 싶어하길래 저도 사고 싶어진
마음이 있었습니다 평소에 그런 식으로
구매하면 손이 잘 안 가는데
그럼에도이 안경은 꾸준히 잘 쓰고
있습니다 젠틀몬스터가 퀄리티에 있어
얼마나 좋은지는 잘 모르겠습니다
그렇지만이적인 부분 는 정말
대단하다고 생각해요 일단 안경
파우치부터 마르젤라 a 글램백
디자인에서 따온게 너무 예뻤습니다
제가 구매한 모델은 템플의 마르젤라
특유의 스티치가 있지 않습니다
스티치가 있는 모델들도 있었지만 저는
개인적으로 그 제품들이 너무 개성이
강해서 사 놓고 안 쓸 것 같더라고요
그래도 안경 팁 쪽에 마르젤라 특유의
넘버링이 들어가 있고 안경 컬렉션에
의미하는 88번의 동그라미가 쳐져
있습니다 공 설명을 보면 에비에이터
안경 형태라고 하는데 일반적인
에비에이터다는 타원 형이라서
상대적으로 부드러운 느낌이 듭니다이
안경을 쓰는 날은 나머지는 무난하게
블랙 앤 화이트로 입으려 합니다
그래서 제가 간절기에 자주 입는
메르츠비 슈바의 헬린 적당히 통해
있는 마카웨어 울 팬츠를 붙여봤습니다
메르츠비 슈바의 헬리 액은 제가
검정색도 갖고 있는데 구매하는
제품마다 만족도가 굉장히 높아서
나중에 한번 소개할 계획입니다 그리고
마르젤라 안경이라서 괜히 마르젤라 a
카라리스 자켓도 오랜만에
꺼내봤습니다 아무튼이 안경은 유려한
모양이다 보니 강한 느낌으로
입기보다는 부드럽고 깔끔하게 입었을
때 더 잘 어울리는
제품입니다 솔직하게 젠틀몬스터의이
제품은 제가 가진 안경 중 자주 쓰는
친구는 아닙니다 마음에 안
들어서라다는 개성이 강하기
때문인데요이 안경 했으면 뭔가 그
엄청 패션을 좋아하는 사람 같다고
해야 할까요 제가 패션을 좋아하고
패션 없게 있는 사람이긴 하지만요
그래서 좀 패션 사람 갖고 싶을 때나
포인트를 주고 싶은 날에
골라서 다음 소개해드릴 제품은 금자
안경 카네코 옵티컬의 KC 치츠
브라운 컬러 안경입니다 이건 도쿄에
갔을 때 구매한 건데 쓴지 만 1년이
되어가는 안경이에요 구매한 직 바로
올리버피플스의 데일리 안경 자리를
가로챈 제품입니다 제가 가진 안경 중
가장 자주 쓰고 있어요이 안경이 손이
많이 가는 이유는 제가 가진 제품 중
가장 편해 선인데요 무게는 올리버
피플스 다 살짝 무겁긴 하지만 그래도
코받침이 있어서 균형잡힌 착용감을
줍니다 오르오르 해 직원분께
들어보니까 모델 이름의 케이시는
카네코 셀룰로이드의 약자라고
하더라고요 흔히 안경에 쓰이는
아세테이트 소재보다 셀룰로이드는 더
강도가 강하고 광택감이 깊고 더
고가의 소재입니다 내구성이 좋고
템플을 보면 철심이 생략된 노심
공법을 쓴 걸 확인할 수 있습니다
설명을 듣긴 했는데이 공법이 어떤
부분에서 좋은 건지는 솔직히 잘
모르겠습니다 그래도 봤을 때 심이 안
보이고 깔끔해서
좋더라고요 우리나라에서 금자 환경으로
불리는 카네코 옵티컬은 1958년에
설립됐습니다
안경제조 기술로 유명한 바라는 도시에
공장을 두고 핸드메이드 작업을 통해
제작을 진행하고 있습니다 좋은
브랜드이고 좋은 안경이지만이 안경을
구매한 솔직한 이유는 일본이 안경으로
유명하다고 해서 일본 브랜드의 안경을
하나 구매하고 싶었고 그런 와중에
카네코 컬의 코받침이 편하다고 해서
여러 제품을 써보다가 가장 잘
어울린다고 생각하는 걸
구매했습니다이 제품은 제가 좋아하는
브 폰의 안경이기 자주 입는 편안하고
따뜻한 색감과 함께
입어봤습니다 위에 입은 캐시미어
집업은 이전 영상들에서 가끔 물어봐
주시는 분들이 계셨는데 몽골 여행
갔다가 구매한 제품이에요 국내에도
유통되는 고비라는 브랜드의 제품인데
몽골 갔을 때 좋은 가격에 기념품
삼아서 구매했습니다 캐시미어 100%
10만 원대였던 걸로 기억해요 안에
입은 셔츠는 최근에 교토에서 구매한
eoss 타이가 타카시의 스트라이프
츠고 아래도 너무나 잘 입고 있는
타이가 타카시의 704
대입니다 아무튼이 안경은 너무
저승사자처럼 어둡게 잊지만 않으면 다
잘 어울리는 것 같습니다 봄에는
흰티랑 청바지에 써줘도 잘 어울리고
간절기에 네이비색 자켓이나 이런
브러운 집업에 입어줘도 좋고요
여러모로 손이 잘 가는지라 여유만
된다면 다른색으로 하나 더 사고 싶은
마음도 있습니다 다만 한가지 아쉬운
점이 있다면 영상 준비하면서
찾아보니까이 모델이 단종 됐다고
하더라고요 그래도 제가 지난 달
교토에 갔을 때 있었으니까 어딘가에는
남아 있을 겁니다 마지막으로
소개해드릴 제품은 가장 최근에 구매한
레스카의 마이오 엑스라지 블랙
제품입니다이 마이오 모델은 몇 달
전에 회사 선배들과 한남동에 갔을 때
오르오르 다른 색상으로 써 봤었어요
그 당시에는 블랙 컬러가 팔리고
없었습니다
그리고 몇 주 전에 친구와 다시
오르오르 갈일이 있었는데 마침이 블랙
컬러가 딱 있더라고요 그래서 써보고
고민하고 있는데 직원분과 친구에게
설득당해서 구매했습니다 물론 매우
만족하는
안경이에요이 안경은 보잉 형태로 된
탑브릿지 자세히 보면 브릿지 중앙에
미세하게 곡선이 있습니다 그래서인지
다른 비슷한 형태 안경보다는 덜
부담스럽더라고요
레카는 에서 1964년에 시작된
브랜드로 예술적이고 클래식한
디자인으로 유명합니다 가장 대표적인
건 많은 분들이 아시는 크라운 판토
제품이에요 대표적인 제품인지라 저도
착용은 해봤는데 제 얼굴이 좀 업데
대해서 그런지 잘 어울리진 않는 거
같더라고요 마이오 그에 비해서
사이즈감이나 착용감이 좋았습니다
물론이 마이어를 썼을 때 그 디즈니
업에 나오는 할아버지가 된듯한 느낌이
들긴 하지만 이런 보잉 형태를
하나쯤은 갖고 싶은 마음이 있었기에
만족하고
있습니다이 제품은 왠지 모르게
차려입은 상태로 쓰고 싶었어요 그래서
가끔 중요한 날 꺼내입는 프라다의
더블 자켓을 같이
입어봤습니다 브이존이 높게 형성된
제품에 찾다가이 프라다 자켓만 마음에
드는 제품이 없어서 젠테 스토어에서
상대적으로 괜찮은 가격에 구매했었어요
물론 큰마음 먹고 샀습니다 왜 안경을
차려입은 상태로 나는 입고 싶을까 그
이유를 곱씹으면서 의식의 흐름을
따라가 보니까 그 끝에는 생로랑 이사
FW 쇼가 있었습니다 입생로랑의
재림이라는 생로랑의 쇼에는 여러
모델들이 안경을 쓰고 나왔습니다 물론
보시다시피 생김새가 레스카의 마이와
매우 달라요 그렇지만 흔히 말하는
잠자리 안경처럼 아리 큰 안경을 쓰고
슈트를 입은 모습이
인상적이어서이 안경을고 어떻게 옷을
입을까 했을 때이 노랑 쇼의 착장이
가장 먼저 랐습니다을 짓고 하자면
이날 이걸 짓고 바로 결혼식에
다녀왔습니다 그래서 마지막에
소개하면서 이대로 입고 갔다 왔어요
하지만이 레스카의 마이오 안경은 안
쓰고
같습니다이 마이오 모델 또한 제게
있어서 젠틀몬스터의 제품처럼 아직까진
매일같이 쓰는 안경은 아닙니다
포인트로 인지라 오랜만에 보는
사람들이 있는 리에서 에 아직
자신감이 없었어요 지금은 좀 자주
쓰면서 익숙해지고 있는 중입니다
레스카인이 모델 말고도 다른 괜찮은
제품들이 너무나도 많으니까요 한번 써
보시는 걸 추천드립니다 개인적으로
한남 르멜 가서 옷들을 둘러보고 바로
옆에 있는 오르오르 가서 그 옷들과
잘 어울리는 안경을 찾는 그 코스가
재밌더라고요 소개해드린 안경 브랜드를
보면 제게 빈티지 안경은 없습니다
빈티지 안경도 몇 차례 시착해 보곤
했는데 서두에 제가 말했듯이 안경에
대한 지식이 많지 않은지라 이에 대한
가치 판단이 전혀 안 되더라고요
그래서 어떤 제품을 얼마에 구매해서
사용하는게 맞는지 몰라서 아직
구매까지 이어진 적은
없습니다 날이 더워질수록 옷을 입는
방식이 단순해지자 아요요 그런 와중에
안경은 내가 입은 옷을 꾸미고 내
인상을 바꾸는 가장 간단한 방법 중
하나입니다 저도 앞으로 좀 더 다양한
안경을 경험해 볼 예정입니다
개인적으로 무태 안경을 좀 찾아보고
있어요 여러분도 한 번쯤 자신에게 잘
어울리는 안경을 찾아 경험해 보시는
걸 추천드립니다 오늘 제 이야기는
여기까지입니다 감사합니다